>> Tucker: ELITES ARE ALWAYS
TELLING YOU HOW PROGRESSIVE
THEY ARE.
TOUT COMMITMENT TO
DIVERSITY.
THEY FRET ABOUT GLOBAL
WARMING.
UP FOR ANY BATHROOM RULE CAN
YOU THINK IT AS LONG AS IT
SOUNDS MODERN.
CLASSIC COOL MOMS EAGER TO
SHOW OFF LIBERAL MINDS.
LIBERALISM ENDS AT THE
WATER'S EDGE.
WHEN IT COMES TO CHINA OUR
GREATEST RIVAL AMERICAN
ELITES BOW DEEPLY TOTALED
DERLY FASCISTS TO RUN THAT
COUNTRY.
WHEN THE CHINESE SAY JUMP
OUR RULING CLASS HAS ONLY
ONE QUESTION HOW HIGH?
CONSIDER GAP THE PROUDLY
LIBERAL CLOTHING OUTFIT.
GAP PULLED A T-SHIRT
WORLDWIDE BECAUSE IT
FEATURED OUTLINE OF CHINA.
THE IMAGE DID NOT INCLUDE
TAIWAN OR GROUP OF OBSCURE
ISLANDS IN SOUTH CHINA SEA.
GAP IMMEDIATELY DESTROYED
THE T-SHIRTS.
OF THE COMPANY ISSUED A
GRABBLE LING PRESS RELEASE.
RESPECT THE TERRITORY OF
CHINA.
FAILED TO REFLECT THE
CORRECT MAP OF CHINA.
IN OTHER WORDS, I'M SORRY
FOR BEING NAUGHTY MOST
HONORABLE SIR.
GAP PROM MISTED IT WOULD
NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
THAT'S ONE OF MANY EXAMPLES.
IN JANUARY, MARRIOTT
APOLOGIZED FOR LISTING
TIBET, TAIWAN AND HONG KONG
ON EMAIL QUESTIONNAIRE.
MARRIOTT FIRED AN EMPLOYEE
WHO LIKED TO TWEET ABOUT IT.
MARRIOTT'S POLICY TO CHINA'S
DICTATOR SAYS IT ALL QUOTE
SOME ASSOCIATES DO NOT
UNDERSTAND OR TAKE SERIOUSLY
ENOUGH THE SOVEREIGNTY AND
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY OF
CHINA OFFENDING CHINA IS NOW
A FIREABLE OFFENSE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AMERICAN EXPRESS, CITY BANK,
GOLDMAN SACHS THEY ALL
AGREE.
THOSE COMPANIES HAVE ALL
CHANGED ONLINE CONTENT TO
ELIMINATION SUGGESTIONS THAT
TAIWAN AND CHINA ARE
SEPARATE COUNTRIES EVEN
THOUGH OF COURSE THEY ARE
SEPARATE COUNTRIES.
CHINESE INSIST AMERICAN
COMPANIES LIE ABOUT THAT SO
THEY DO.
HOLLYWOOD HAS BEEN DOING IT
FOR YEARS.
MOVIE STUDIOS HAVE BEEN
OBEDIENT FOR CHINA'S RULERS
40S MORE HA DECADE.
ASK RICHARD GEAR THE ACTOR.
HE HAS TROUBLE GETTING WORK
BECAUSE VIEWS ON DID
BECAUSE VIEWS ON TID
BECAUSE VIEWS ON TIBET
OFFEND CHINESE OFFICIALS.
THE MOVIE DR. STRANGE
PRODUCERS CAST A WHITE WOMAN
IN THE ROLE OF A TIBET
CONTINUE CHARACTER.
WHY DID THEY DO THAT?
DOESN'T SOUND LINING THE
DIVERSITY DOCTRINE AT WORK.
WHY?
SCREEN WRITER ETHIC TIBET
TAN WOULD MAKE CHINA MAD.
CHANGED THE BAD GUY FROM
CHINA TO NORTH KOREA.
WHY?
YOU KNOW BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
WANT TO OFFEND BEIJING.
HOW EAGER ARE AMERICAN
ELITES TO DO THE BIDDING OF
THEIR CHINESE MASTERS?
ASK YOURSELF THIS.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THE
DALAI LAMA.
REMEMBER HIM?
HE USED TO BE A HERO TO
AMERICANS.
ESPECIALLY AMERICAN
LIBERALS.
YOU NEVER HEAR HIS NAME
ANYMORE.
CHINA GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
LIKE HIM.
UNDER PRESSURE FROM THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT HIS
APPEARANCES BY THE DALAI
LAMA HAVE BEEN CANCELLED
AROUND THE WORLD INCLUDING
SHAMEFULLY IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE DALAI LAMA MAY BE A
GREAT MORAL LEADER BUT CHINA
PAYS THE BILLS.
FRANK WOLF IS A RARE FORMER
MEMBER OF CONGRESS WHO HAS
BEEN SOUNDING THE ALARM ON
CHINA FOR A VERY LONG TIME
AND HE JOINS US NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, I'M GRATEFUL TO
HAVE YOU.
YOU REALLY ARE ONE OF THE
VERY FEW FORMER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO IS POINTING OUT
THE HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES IN
CHINA AND IS WILLING TO SAY
WHAT IS TRUE, WHICH IS THEY
ARE BULLYING US.
WHY IS THAT?
WHY AREN'T MORE SAYING IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW, TUCKER.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
142 DID I BETIAN MONKS
POURED KEROSENE ON BODIES
AND SET THEIR BODIES AFLAME.
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN BEING
TAKEN AWAY TO DETENTION
CAMPS.
>> Tucker: RIGHT NOW.
>> RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: MUSLIMS ARE BEING
ROUNDED UP.
>> THOUSANDS.
MANY, MANY, MANY THOUSANDS
IN DETENTION CAMP.
ALMOST LIKE STALINIST CAMPS
AND CATHOLIC BISHOPS MISSING
MISSING.
HOLY COMMUNION FROM BISHOP
AS YOU HE HAS NEVER BEEN
SEEN AGAIN.
PROTESTANT PASTORS ARE BEING
ARRESTED.
IT IS AS BAD TODAY AS IT HAS
EVER BEEN SINCE MAO.
RICHARD GERE WILL NEVER MAKE
ANOTHER MOVIE.
ANC HAS BEEN SOLD TO THE
CHINESE.
OTHER STUDIOS HAVE BEEN
SOLD.
THEY CENSOR YOU AND CENSOR
YOU SAY IF YOU RUN THAT
RICHARD GERE WILL NEVER BE A
N. A MAJOR MOVIE.
>> Tucker: WITHOUT NAMING
NAMES THIS IS A VERY SMALL
CITY AND HAVE YOU BEEN HERE
A LONG TIME LOOKING OUT
ACROSS THE CITY YOU KNOW A
LOT OF LOBBYISTS A LOT
SERVED IN CONGRESS.
WHAT PERCENTAGE WOULD YOU
SAY ARE ON THE PAYROLL ARE
CHINA.
>> I WILL SAY SOME NAMES.
ONE OF THE BIGGER NAMES IN
TOWN SQUIRES PAT AND BOGS.
THEY REPRESENT THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
THEY ALSO REPRESENT BASHIR
THE INDICTED WAR CRIMINAL
FROM SUDAN WHO HAS BEEN
INDICTED FOR GENOCIDE.
SQUIRE, BOGGS.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU SAY
MANY DIFFERENT LOBBYING
OUTFIT AND FIRMS IN
WASHINGTON TAKE MONEY FROM
THE CHINESE INTERESTS?
>> YES, THEY DO.
WHAT IS INTERESTING, DURING
THE 1980S WHEN I GOT ELECTED
WHEN RONALD REAGAN WAS HERE.
NO COMPANY, NO PR FIRM.
NO LAW FIRM WOULD HAVE EVER
REPRESENTED THE SOVIET
UNION.
NOW SO MANY ARE
REPRESENTING, SQUIRES,
PATTON BOGGS TO REPRESENT
BESHEAR, THE PRESIDENT OF
SUDAN WHO IS AN INDICTED WAR
CRIMINAL FOR GENOCIDE.
WHAT TOOK PLACE IN DARFUR.
THE STANDARDS IN THIS TOWN
HAVE TOTALLY CHANGED.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THAT
MAY BE CONNECTED TO THE FACT
THAT ALMOST YOU HEAR A LOT
ABOUT RUSSIA BUT YOU NEVER
HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT CHINA'S
HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES.
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
CONNECTED?
>> THE HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
AND LACK OF RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM IS WORSE TODAY IN
CHINA THAN IT'S BEEN SINCE
THE DAYS OF MAO.
DON'T FORGET PRESIDENT XI
HAS NOW APPOINTED HIMSELF
PRESIDENT FOR LIFE IT IS
TERRIBLE.
THAT'S WHY I CAN'T
UNDERSTAND.
THE VERY FACT THAT THOUSANDS
OF MUSLIM KIDS ARE BEING
TAKEN AWAY.
I HAD A MUSLIM WOMAN COME BY
MY OFFICE ABOUT TWO MONTHS
AGO.
35 OF HER GRAND CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN TAKEN AND PUT IN
THESE DETENTION CAMPS.
I URGE YOU TO GOOGLE.
>> Tucker: I'M GOING TO.
YOU JUST CONVINCED ME NEXT
WEEK WE ARE GOING TO DO A
SEGMENT ON CHINESE HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES.